and talk to you just a little bit about
progress on some analysis tools we're
developing for studying manuscripts and
these are just a couple of projects
underway that are part of a larger
umbrella project on digitally enabled
scholarship with medieval manuscripts
that's being led by meg Bellinger and
and Barbara schaller and the two main
aspects were working on these days is
analyzing the visual layout of the pages
in medieval manuscripts and looking at
some of the material properties of pages
in manuscripts in particular the
reflectance of the material that that
the manuscript says is made of so for
document layouts there's in the
collections of manuscripts were looking
at in particular a set of manuscripts
that were looking at with Jessica
Brantley she's interested in books of
ours there's there's a wide variety of
ways that things are laid out on the
page we have some things that are all
text there are texts with marginal notes
that are our texts combined with
illustrations either around the border
or in the middle of the text and then of
course there are some pages that are
purely illustration and what we want to
do is in her case she's looking at these
books of ours and the the text content
of different books of ours is largely
the same that's the point there their
standard prayers and that that's the
purpose of making these books what's
interesting is to pull out the things
that are that vary in the various
manuscripts and so what we'd like to do
is of the thousands and thousands of
pages of different books of ours be able
to do things like pull out say
particular words or in the case SI in
the center here you see some sort of
blue and brown bars
those are laid out indicating that this
section is verse and and so we'd like to
be able to pull out of the pages of
savers or things that that maybe
Jessica's not interested in her study
but in future studies people may be
interested in seeing like well how were
you know what is the variety of how
leaves are represented it's how our face
is represented we'd like to do some
analysis of the layout of the pages that
can be of use in Jessica study and also
do a lot of processing that can be speed
up future studies of the manuscripts ah
I'm going backwards okay so so what we
want to do is be a be able to analyze
what's in these pages and the foot and
the idea is a basic technique from
computer science i mean it's it's it's
you know the term we actually use divide
and conquer and so the first thing you
want to do and analyzing the layout is
identify this is text this is not text
because if you're going to look for a
specific word there's no point in
looking for a word in in the middle of a
picture you want to just if you're going
to look for a word you want to look in
the pages that are text and the same way
if you're going to look for these boxes
that indicate verse there's no point in
looking at them in a page that's only
text so our first step in analyzing
these these pages is to distinguish
between texts not text and for printed
books this is this is a done deal it's
not a problem that's the nature of print
being very regular but it's a problem in
the variety of pages we see in
manuscripts and to identify text not
text the first thing we need to do is
identify the height of the text and you
know because typically there are a lot
of algorithms out there for analyzing
pages and step one is to go in and give
the algorithm that the typical height
text on the page or in the book and then
the algorithm goes on but since we want
to study massive collections we don't
want to have people having to go in and
enter oh this is how high the text is
here this is how high the text is here
so not to to bore you to a larger extent
but just to give you an idea of why is
this computer science research what we
want to do is find a way that's robust
for estimating the height of the text
that works without us having looked at
the page you know when looking at the
page no and making any estimates and
this is just one one diagram showing
giving sort of the gist of the technique
which is to look at the page look at
sections of the page look at subsections
of the page and what we do every time we
subdivide the page is we compute
correlation coefficients how how how
much is one one point and the page like
another point and these horizontal lines
indicate you know directions where
things are staying the same whereas when
they when they go from from white to
black things are varying so we can see
where there's a picture we don't see any
nice neat patterns but when we have txt
we see this very regularly periodic
pattern and we can compute from that
from the size of the periods what the
text height is now obviously not you
know we since it's not all text that's
why we do this break it down break it
down so when we have mainly picture we
get no period we get something DISA T
that's a little bit interrupted when
there's a bit of illustration in with
the text and we get a nice clean signal
when we have all text so we go through
all the pages and perform this analysis
and get an estimate of text type for
each piece at each level and then by
combining those estimates for each page
ultimately getting an estimate for each
page for the text that's on that page
what is the typical height so it's more
you know blatantly obvious in this
text in this printed edition that we get
36 pixels indicated by that little red
box so we we took this algorithm and ran
it on about 7,000 manuscript pages and
here are some typical results of various
kinds of pages that have different
combinations of text and an image and
one question you say well great you
ranted on 7,000 pages how do you know
yet the right answer that that's a
difficult question also first of all we
took a hundred pages at random and went
through and actually measured how high
the texts were on the page and compared
that to the estimate we got we got
generally with well within fifteen
percent of what you would measure
manually and what's significant is if
you go across an individual page and
look at the text height variation often
you see as a 15-percent variation so
that's really as good as we can expect
to get we also for all seven thousand
pages went through and and plotted
little boxes of the size that we
estimated text height on each page so
that you could go through and visually
inspect is that little box the same
height as the text mine and overall out
of the seven thousand pages we had about
a ninety nine percent success rate and
so well but I mean these pages look
pretty you know they don't look that
hard why is this a big deal well we have
a you know we these are sight unseen we
have a lot of really damaged manuscripts
where there's big splotches to confuse
things we have manuscripts that are
faded and so we don't have whole letters
but still we're getting the right
answers generally people are fairly
careful about their digitizing but but
you know laying a book flat can be
difficult so we also get some skewing we
still get the right answer and the
advantage of doing this break up the
page break up the page break up the page
is we can get a good estimate even when
the page isn't full of text or when it's
it's it's mainly full of other things we
can still get some some good results
there are some damage and also there's
the problem of bleeding through but that
that signal is fainter than the signal
that we're looking at so we were quite
quite pleased that we now have this
automatic method there are cases that
are failures but but we know why their
failures these are so-called calendar
pages and we don't have continuous
breaks between the lines on this
calendar page that there are there are
vertical sets of characters that run
together so even when it fails it's
telling you something about to those
pages we got some rather absurdly large
text height and that actually can be
perhaps a way of hey pick out all of the
the calendar pages so I have a out of
order so so now this is the first step
in our divide and conquer that we can we
can identify text height by using using
that in the course of doing that we were
also able to immediately separate out of
any any manuscript pages that have no
text and then the next thing we can do
is identify lines of text for the
purposes say of associating
transcriptions because now we know the
size window to look at to examine is
this text how far does this text extend
and we can also then identify various
elements of illustration and pull those
out for example to identify the verse or
to identify the way various letters are
made so a layout is one thing and even
though we now say in in vogue we're not
going to be interested in identifying
text and images because it is print the
same principle of you know finding
techniques to look at different layouts
could be applied to start pulling out
more details of the visual form so it's
not completely unrelated to the
previous work the other aspect of the of
analyzing the manuscripts is looking at
not just what do they say what do they
look like but material aspects of the
work to better understand who made these
how did they make them and by doing
multispectral imaging rather than
standard camera imaging we can get a
plot of the reflectance at different
wavelengths at a relatively crude scale
but at a scale that starts letting us
differentiate between the different
materials on the page it may not let us
identify those materials but we can
perhaps say how many materials were used
on this page does the spectrum of the
materials vary as we go through the
manuscript and all these things can be
clues to how was the manuscript produced
who produced it just to give you a
little bit of introduction about
multispectral capture it's been around a
long time but suddenly it's become a
very hot topic in the in the cultural
heritage arena instead of having sensors
in the camera that are matching human
visual response they have sharp bands in
the visible spectrum that so you can
identify where in the visible spectrum
light came from we also can measure the
the near-uv and the I are things that
you can't see that further help us
analyze what's on the page well how was
it made its high dynamic range which
means that you have less burnout and
less to dark area areas that are too
dark and we can actually using this
estimate the physical property of
reflectance rather than color and when I
it's a significant difference spectral
reflectance is a physical property color
is in your head it's it's only as
meaningful to people so we're dealing
with the fact that that might itself is
composed of
light of different wavelengths and if we
look at the different materials that are
used in in and in manuscripts they could
have rather similar spectra that
appeared to have the same color but that
you can differentiate if you see the
spectra just to give you an idea of this
we see we form the idea of color because
of how light reflects at us and if there
is a certain spectrum of light it
reflects into our I and we get this idea
of color but the problem is with cameras
that are tuned to produce our sense of
color red radically different spectra
can give us the same idea of color so we
can't discriminate between things on the
page the well as well as if we recorded
the spectrum just another example of
radically different spectral that looked
like the same color so so instead of
using a standard camera that gives you
RGB values we use a specialized imager
that that has a set of charge-coupled
devices with different filter windows
and we we specify those windows to more
sharply isolate the spectral bands
rather than using the the bands that
that simulate how your how the rods in
your eye work and so just to to
summarize then we can get get
comparisons of what the materials look
like at different points in the page is
the flourishing does that seem to be the
same pigment as say the rubric was on
the page we've since that example we've
improved our equipment we use eight
bands now and the people actually doing
this aren't here because they are on our
tour of the UK they've been in Oxford
Cambridge this week and then they're
going back to Wales and their imaging a
number of manuscripts for support of
this project and the next step in that
is there going to be doing things like a
doing massive studies of multiple pages
to analyze the changes in in pigment
spectra and the the variations of
pigment spectra on on various pages and
also we're developing a tool for
scholars to use so they can go in and
probe and look at am I seeing really a
difference in color are these are these
really different and a way of exporting
their observations so that's just a
couple of works in progress and the
people actually doing the work rogerio
Pentos and yang Yang as I said they
should be here presenting it but they're
they're traveling and with the support
from the larger project from YDC to Meg
ballinger Lewis King Michael Appleby and
then Jessica Brantley and Barbara
schaller the scholars actually
interested in the manuscripts that were
we're trying to analyze and this is all
of melon funded project thank you thank
you very much